you
many thousands of years ago in East Asia
there existed a mighty creature the
woolly mammoth popularized by the
discovery of cave paintings skeletons
and even entire frozen carcasses this
furry giant captured the public's
attention with the thought of a
real-life Jurassic Park scenario could
we resurrect this ancient relative of
the Asian elephant almost six years ago
a team of Japanese scientists predicted
they would successfully clone a woolly
mammoth within five years so where is it
before we get into the how let's look at
why people are so interested in the
possibility of bringing back the
mammoths for the scientific community
recreating an extinct creature would be
an historic first for the first time in
history scientists could compare their
deductions about an extinct creature
with a living breathing specimen for
zoos and Parks it would be a huge
attraction think what you could charge
for admission to see the first
successfully cloned woolly mammoths and
of course for the public it would be
just like living Jurassic Park just
without all the actual dinosaurs and
horrific carnage now back to the how in
2013 a well preserved mammoth carcass
was discovered in Siberia this specimen
nicknamed buttercup created a ripple of
excitement in the scientific community
because it contained what was referred
to as red fluid thought to be blood if
so much as one single intact cell
nucleus could be found in a red blood
cell scientists could insert it into an
elephant egg and implant the egg into a
surrogate mother elephant to bear the
child unfortunately the news came in
2014 the scientists found no such red
blood cells if a better preserved
mammoth carcass is discovered and if it
does contain intact red blood cells
the next problem scientists will face is
how exactly to retrieve an elephant egg
implant the mammoth DNA and then return
the fertilized egg to date no one has
figured out even the first step
obtaining the egg one expert of
genetically engineered animals and
professor at Texas A&M said taking the
nucleus out of one cell and transferring
it to another that's easy you can do
that in labs all over the world but all
the other things that have to come
together to make an animal is difficult
getting the eggs to begin with another
avenue that scientists are considering
is using genome editing techniques to
essentially build mammoth DNA the same
technology that allows the editing of
human DNA as referenced in my previous
video might also allow scientists to
introduce traits found in mammoths into
elephants these traits include hair
attributes ear shape and subcutaneous
fat among others
many scientists believe that starting
with a modern elephant is the best
approach they suspect that their most
likely won't be the extinction of woolly
mammoths exactly how they existed
thousands of years ago instead they
expect to see a genetically modified
elephant with mammoth traits that would
allow it to adapt to the mammoth
traditional icy habitats first the
edited genetic code would be inserted
into elephant stem cells which would be
carefully nurtured and developed into
what are called organoids
which are cellular structures that
perform organ functions in the lab after
a few years of tests in a laboratory
environment the fully edited genome
could be inserted into the egg of an
Asian elephant as it's the closest
genomic match from their if the
development and birth went off without
any problems we would see the first
hybrid mammoths not quite woolly
mammoths but not quite elephant either
if at some point in the future
scientists were able to reintroduce
mammoths into the wild it would be more
than just a cloning achievement
returning such a key species to the
Tundra's could even help stave off some
of the effects of global warming in the
Pleistocene era when mammoths roamed the
barren landscapes of the tundra their
foraging for grass buried beneath the
snow had the positive effect of exposing
the ground to Arctic chill keeping it
thoroughly frozen this kept the co2
trapped in the permafrost from being
released into the atmosphere and warming
the climate in some tests it's been
determined that soil where large animals
are present is around 30 degrees
Fahrenheit colder than soil in areas
without the animals so when can we
expect to see attempts at birthing a
mammoth some groups put the estimate as
early as 2018 a group at Harvard as well
as sue on biotech the group that will
clone your dog for $100,000 are both
working on it as we speak
of course there are ethical concerns to
take into consideration elephants are
very intelligent very social animals
it's not yet apparent how they might
react to being subjected to tests and
many potential failed births would the
baby even be accepted by the elephant
community after all mammoths are about
as closely related to Asian elephants as
humans are to chimpanzees for some
insight as to what an early cloned
mammoths life might look like we can
look back to dolly the first-ever
successfully cloned animal Dolly the
sheep was born in 1996 and was plagued
by severe health issues such as
arthritis and progressive lung disease
she only lived about half the normal
lifespan of the typical sheep dying at
six years old however in a 2016 study in
which 13 sheep were cloned not one of
them displayed any indication of poor
health such studies seem to indicate the
dollie was a fluke and that cloning
should not negatively affect the subject
but we'll just have to wait and see one
interesting thing to note is that the
woolly mammoth wouldn't be the first
extinct animal to be cloned in January
of 2009 scientists from the center of
food technology and research of Aragon
announced that they had more or less
successfully cloned appear Indian ibex a
type of mountain goat that was declared
extinct in 2000 they said more or less
successful because the clone lived a
short life dying shortly after its birth
due to physical defects in his lungs so
back to the topic of the woolly mammoth
do scientists have the means to
successfully clone a woolly mammoth
provided they find the intact cells to
work with yes would the mammoth be born
with or develop health issues possibly
there's still speculation on whether or
not clones have a higher likelihood of
developing health problems compared to
naturally born animals should you
subscribe to this channel and like this
video yes yes you should as always my
videos are intended to spark your
interest in these topics if you want to
learn more about cloning and the quest
to bring back the woolly mammoth check
out the links and resources in the
description if you enjoyed this video
please take a moment to subscribe to my
channel your support makes all the
difference feel free to leave a like or
a comment below and let me know what you
think of the idea of cloning extinct
species you can watch my previous video
by clicking here or watch them all by
clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you next week
[Music]
you
[Music]